la presencia de líderes latinoamericanos
está siendo escasa en estos primeros dos
días de la Cumbre de alto nivel en la
co-27 en sermel say el lunes habló
Gustavo Petro el presidente de Colombia
quien en su decálogo de ideas propuesto
abogó porque la solución al cambio
climático es dejar de una vez por todas
los hidrocarburos y anunció que Colombia
dedicará 200 millones de dólares al año
para salvaguardar la amazonía e invito a
otros países a unirse a esta propuesta
Nicolás Maduro el presidente de
Venezuela por su parte Aunque llegó el
sábado y dio su mensaje hoy el lunes
ayer tuvo un breve encuentro con el
presidente francés Emanuel macron quien
a pesar de no reconocer a maduro como
presidente legítimo de Venezuela le
pidió un encuentro bilateral que sea
útil para la región y para su país antes
de su mensaje al resto de líderes
Nicolás Maduro habló con Franz 24 sobre
lo que pide su país un mes después de
que Venezuela se viera afectada por
graves inundaciones y deslaves
escuchamos somos Víctimas de esa crisis
climática aquí se está exigiendo
compromiso
para el financiamiento para la
recuperación de las zonas que tienen que
ser recuperadas el financiamiento para
los países que han sufrido daños en uno
de los grandes temas de esta Cumbre y
compromiso para
comenzar a cumplir los acuerdos que ya
se firmaron en París de reducción de
gases de efecto invernadero de los
grandes contaminadores del mundo maduro
también habló sobre la postura de
Gustavo Petro en la cop 27 y sobre la
relación de los países amazónicos que
ahora puede mejorar con la llegada a la
presidencia de Lula en Brasil creo que
el presidente Petro Tuvo una posición
muy clara muy contundente con una
propuesta de un decálogo para enfrentar
el tema del cambio climático y yo creo
que en general en la región de América
Latina y el Caribe esta situación va
agarrando fuerza presidente Petro ha
propuesto y estoy seguro con el
presidente Lula da Silva lo va a asumir
como tal a ser una cumbre en el primer
trimestre del año 2023 de los países
amazónicos y de allí surja un proceso de
diálogo con los Estados Unidos de
Norteamérica para ir a un proceso de
preservación y de regeneración del